hi everyone
my name is james soh i am a assistant
professor at stanford university
and i will tell you a little bit about
some of the recent work that we've been
doing
in developing computer vision algorithms
to study genomics
and in particular to study genomics
across
different spatial variations and also
across temporal variations
and this also be an opportunity to give
a tutorial of how we can actually
leverage some of the recent advances
in deep learning or computer vision
great so to set the stage for this
presentation
right so i want all of us to do a
thought experiment together
so imagine if i've given you a list of
descriptions of
an individual right so here i've given
you a
list of descriptions which could be
taken from a medical record
or from clinical notes and what would i
like you to do is to try to visualize in
your head
as much as possible of what the face of
this person looked like
all right just take a couple seconds to
do that
okay and now i'm actually show you the
actual face right so this is
the actual face of this individual and
you can see
how well your division in your heads
whether it agreed well was this image or
not
right so the faces of this individual is
actually very interesting but this is
taken from a new england journal of
medicine article from a few years ago
so it's actually the face of a truck
driver and one that's quite notable is
that
this truck driver is the face is
actually quite asymmetric
right so you see one side of the face is
actually much more wrinkly
and sag compared to the other side and
this is really because of the
exposure to the sun right when the truck
driver is driving on one side and the
window
is closer to that side of the face and
it's a really nice image because first
it captures
quite vividly right this interaction
between the environment
and between the the environmental
exposures between underlying
biology of this individual and how this
all affects the health status and
disease
outcomes of this individual but it also
captures that i think a really important
point which is that there's actually a
lot of
information very rich information in the
images
right and that's actually very hard to
capture with
your you know with the standard text
descriptions
right because if we actually go back and
look at the text right
um just based on this my vision of what
this person looked like is actually very
different
much less rich and limited compared to
this actual image
but the text would maybe have a few
bytes of information
right but whereas the image itself could
actually contains megabytes or even
gigabytes of information
and this is the case for you know for
even for
images of humans or faces something that
we're quite familiar with
right and the problem is even more stark
and
even a bigger challenge if we're
thinking about how to describe
objects that are even smaller all right
so here i actually have an image of a
tumor biopsy from breast cancer tumor
right and this is actually just uh and
on the right here we actually actually
have a
individual cell it's a microglia it's
kind of an immune cell which i'll come
back to in a little bit
and here we have the motion from a
microscope
of this individual cell right so how
would we even describe this
these objects right so that's actually
quite challenging
because and the reason what's
challenging is because in english
we really lack a very precise vocabulary
with which to describe the phenotypes
and morphologies and dynamics
of these objects right it's hard enough
for us to even precisely describe
faces of individuals it's even harder
for us to describe these smaller objects
like biopsies and individual cells
and this is really the motivation for
this talk and for a lot of my research
right when we think that's the recent
advances in computer vision
right the goal is to really use those
computer vision technologies
to enable us to more deeply and more
precisely phenotype
is objects that would be hard for us to
describe otherwise
and in particular we want to use
computer vision and to use these deep
learning algorithms
to basically create a new vocabulary a
new language of
morphology and this language actually
then describes objects across
different physical scales from the scale
of individual cells
to that of humans and organisms
a lot of the work in my group is
actually in developing these computer
vision algorithms
right so and and and many of these are
actually also
widely used by some of the companies
that you're familiar with
right and a lot of the really
advancedness in computer vision recently
it's based on advances in sort of
artificial neural networks
all right so i'll give some more
examples of this throughout the talk but
let's say if you want to build you know
like
in this case like a self-driving car
right then you would like to have the
car to be able to
look at the surroundings and to identify
what are other cars and what are other
individuals
right so you should be able to detect
these different objects and to con
to characterize what they are and in a
nutshell
the kinds of algorithms that people
currently use to detect
and to classify these different objects
using computer vision and using
self-driving cars
are really based on these different
layers of convolutional neural networks
so it's the particular type
of a deep learning algorithm and what
these algorithms are doing
again this is just an overview which
i'll come back to in a little bit
is they're basically scanning across
this image right so let's say if you are
trying to detect the particular car
then the convolutional neural network
will scan across this image
right and so each column here
corresponds to one layer
of the convolutional network so the
initial layers right so these are the
columns to the left here
are looking for local objects right in
this car
so maybe it's looking for wheels or it's
looking for
windows and some of the later layers so
the columns that are in the middle or to
the right
are looking for higher level or more
abstract concepts
right and these layers come together in
the end to come up with a classification
with this algorithm that classifies with
some confidence whether this is a car
or a truck or an airplane so the goal of
this talk is to
give you a tutorial and to illustrate
how we can apply these algorithms
instead of looking for cars and for you
know for computer vision tasks tests
in the world how can we can actually use
these technologies to really help
us to understand spatial variations in
genomics
as well as temporal variations temporal
dynamics in individual cells
in a way that's directly relevant for
human diseases
okay so how would we actually think
about using these vision technologies
for pathology right for to understand
spatial heterogeneity
and genomic heterogeneity so the setting
that we're working with here
is actually in uh in histology right so
here's just uh here i'm showing you on
the on the
top left is a standard kind of image
histology image taken from a breast
cancer patient
right so these are kind of the routine
image that people commonly generate
and the pathologists would often look at
these images by eye
right and make some assessments and and
diagnosis
of the of the stages or the out
of this patient all right so on the
bottom left here we actually have
actually the
clinical annotations by the pathologist
of where
in this image he or she believes to
correspond to
tumor regions and where actually
corresponds to normal cells normal
regions
right so these histology images are
widely used and they're very powerful
because
it allows you to really capture spatial
heterogeneity
right of different cells and different
different parts of the tissue
different parts of the tumor in real
time and
in real space
in parallel as many of you know so
there's also
a very powerful set of technologies
based on genomics and more recently
based on single cell genomics
which captures you know quite a
complementary orthogonal types of
information
right so typically what people do here
then would be they will take these
biopsy samples they have to dissolve the
cells right to extract the individual
single cells
and once they dissolve and extract
individual cells then they can
do single cell for example transcripton
measurements or single cell sequencings
to capture the expression profiles of
those individual isolated cells
so these two different technologies both
have pros and cons
right so the advantage of the single
cell of the genomic analysis is that
first you actually have much richer
information right for every individual
cell if you
do rna-seq you actually have a lot of
genes
you know thousands of genes that are
being measured
the disadvantage the downside is that
you actually lose the original spatial
information right you don't know which
location in the tissue this cell comes
from so you lose
actually the bigger context the
advantage of the histology imaging this
current pathology workflow is that you
do have the spatial context right
because you have the original tissue
but the up the measurements you see are
fairly limited information right maybe
you see this is normal or
no this is normal or malignant but you
don't actually really have the
informations about all this rich gene
expression
of thousands of genes for for
for these images right so there's
certainly a trade-off between the two
and what we have been doing recently is
to actually use computer vision
to develop new technologies that allow
us to get the best of both worlds right
so you have both the
spatial imaging data and at the same
time you also have rich
genomic readouts that are spatially
resolved
so here's just an example application of
our algorithm which we call the
st net algorithm so here's the
input example right so on the we have
the histology image that we saw before
from breast cancer patients from a
biopsy
and the st net our algorithm is able to
impute the computational synthesize
spatial variations
in gene expression profiles right so for
example let's say if you're interested
in this gene
fasten which is one of the breast camera
breast cancer biomarkers then the st net
will be able to impute
the expression profile for fasting on
top of this histology image it will tell
you
the parts in yellow are the places where
the fasting is highly expressed
and parts in blue is where this gene
slowly expressed
and if you're interested in a different
gene right if you have just
have a second gene here then the
algorithm also
synthesizes and instantaneously imputes
the
gene expression profiles for the second
gene
and what's this this algorithm right now
we can actually impute the expression
profiles that are spatially resolved
for over a hundred genes and
we have experimental measurements right
actually using the spatial
transcriptomic technologies which i'll
describe in the next slide
to validate the computations from the
algorithm
and they're actually in very good
agreements here right so this is done
on a on one of the test patients
so just to be just to you know make sure
everything's clear right so the second
column here these are computational
predictions that are synthesized
gene expression profiles directly from
the histology image
right and then on the right here right
the third column corresponds to the
experimental measurements that we can
use to
validate uh these computational
predictions and they're in good
agreements
and if we have a different patient right
if you have a second patient right
maybe you have a different biopsy sample
a different histology image that's also
fine right the algorithm will take a
look
at just this raw histology image and
it's able to actually make
profiles right for this gene expression
of fasom and
also for 100 other genes and that also
agrees quite well with
experimental measurements right and this
is also quite interesting here right
because this
image itself was the standard clinical
annotations the pathology would actually
say that oh this entire image is almost
uniformly made of tumor regions
whereas the algorithms is able to detect
that even within all of these tumor
regions
there is still substantial spatial
variation
in expressions of these key tumor genes
and these key markers and that can be
very useful
for more fine-grained and more precise
prognosis
as well as for treatment planning so
this work was recently published right
and it's uh and you can find the the
paper detail here it's published
a couple of months ago in nature
biomedical engineering
okay so now i want to take a few minutes
to explain
a little bit more detail of how we
actually develop this algorithm
how do we validate it and apply it right
so to train the algorithm right we
actually need to collect
actual experimental data that are
spatially of resolved
transcriptomes and this is actually done
in collaboration with my fantastic
collaborator joker bloomberg who is one
of the really the pioneers who developed
these spatial transaction technologies
so how it works the nutshells the
following let's say if you have a breast
cancer biopsy
right there's a tiny little biopsy and
what you do is that
yoko has developed this chip right so i
have an example of this chip here
you basically overlay this biopsy tissue
on top
directly on top of the chip now what's
special about the chip that you can
develop is that you actually have
little probes on the chip right so
there's our little dots here in our
cartoon
and each probe actually corresponds to a
set of
barcoded basically barcoded needles
right so think of this each probe as
corresponds to like a zip code that
tells you
where is the xy location of that probe
and what happens when you overlay the
tissue on top of this chip
is that these little needles will
basically puncture and get into the cell
right and once it gets into the cell
they actually detect some
transcripts in the cell right they would
actually then attach the barcode
the spatial zip code on no on top of the
transcripts
and the beauty of this is that now when
we actually sequence
the cells afterwards now we know exactly
where
the transcript comes from right because
we have the barcode the zip code
attached
to the transcript so that's how we can
experimentally measure
that for this gene fasom right that's
what they'll be here are the regions in
the middle where it's highly expressed
and the surrounding areas where it has
low expressions whereas for a different
gene
xvp1 you have different special
expression patterns
and this is quite high throughput in the
sense that we can actually do this
and then be able to measure expression
values of several hundred to thousands
of genes
in parallel
okay so this is the training data that
we generated
to train and to validate our algorithm
st net
right and sdnet itself it's actually
very similar to this kind of uh
you know image recognition or
self-driving car kinds of computer
machine algorithms i showed you a few
slides ago
right so in a nutshell what stnet is
doing sets it's also scanning across the
individual image
right so it's looking at the local
patches i'll show you some examples here
right so each local patch
is around 100 to 150 microns right so
it's quite small
and the st net algorithm is scanning
across those patches it learns
what are the important features
automatically what are the important
features in each of those patches
and that's what we're calling this
latent representation
and once it learns the representation
then it uses that information to impute
the expression profiles of hundreds of
genes
right uh at each of those locations for
each of the probes
all right so this is the algorithms
trained and what's this is actually able
to impute
the expression profiles of 400 genes
right and
it's able to do that at resolutions
around 100 microns each so it's actually
fairly high
spatial resolutions
so this was done on breast cancer
patients
and we actually did a lot of rigorous
testing to evaluate that algorithm
really works well
right so the best way to do testing is
that you really take very independent
patients independent data
so here we actually use data just
generated by a different group it's
actually generated by 10x genomics
so a different company then they have
different ways to collect these samples
and even different
different imaging protocols different
sequencing protocols
so this is actually quite a strong test
to see what are the algorithm that we've
developed on our set of breast cancer
patients
how well it will work on a very
different set of data
also from breast cancer patients
generated in this different environment
different contexts by 10x
and actually works quite well remarkably
well right so each dot here
corresponds to one gene right so the x
and y
axis corresponds to the performance of
the algorithm
in predicting the spatial expression
profile of that gene
on two different test data sets
um and so the auc is basically one of
the common measures
of how what algorithms doing and we can
see here in the top right corner
here i highlighted that in in the red
circle but there's actually
over 100 genes where the algorithm st
net actually is making
very reliable predictions as compared to
the experimental ground truth
measured on these both of these test
sets all right so these are the hundred
genes where they have auc above 0.8
above 0.9
and these are 100 genes where we think
that the algorithm can really
quite reliably generate computationally
generate these spatial profiles
and it's 100 genes also captures many of
the key genes that we're interested in
right so these include
cancer biomarkers immune markers as well
as genes that are really important for
the mobility and architectures of the
cells
so the the beauty and the power of this
kind of approach is that once we train
the algorithm
now we can actually do this and apply
this to new data
or where we don't have the corresponding
experimental measurements
right because the experimental
measurements while it's it's great but
it's actually quite expensive
and can be quite time consuming to still
degenerate right so there's still only a
few groups
around that can reliably generate these
high throughput spatial
transcriptional measurements but the
algorithm once we have developed it
that can be applied potentially to you
know to any image
including archival images that uh
labs and clinics have already collected
right and we have we have actually tried
this we know we applied to our algorithm
and uh let's train on our breast cancer
data and we actually applied it to
images from archives from tcga and we
also showed that they work quite
well there and we can also use the
output of this algorithm right to
quantify a variety of things including
tumor hydrogenity
as well as to the extent to which the
immune cells are infiltrating into these
different tumor regions
which can be captured from this um from
the
uh synthesized expression profiles
it's also very interesting to us to see
what is it that these deep learning
computation algorithms are looking at
when trying to understand the predict
the expression profiles of different
genes
all right so for example here we're
showing the sort of
zoomed in version of this of the biopsy
and highlighted in the bottom row are
the regions where the algorithm estimate
is paying attention to when it decides
whether
this each region actually has high
fastened expression
right so fast and again it's a breast
cancer referee breast cancer biomarkers
it's actually quite interesting because
here the algorithm actually learns to
focus
to focus its attention to relatively uh
a few locations in the input which
course actually corresponds to these
enlarged
nuclei in the cells right so the parts
where it's paying
a large attention to and then red
regions actually correspond to these
nuclei regions
so that algorithm actually learned by
itself that if you actually have
enlarged nuclei it's actually
symptomatic
of high expression for this tumor factor
spasm
so this demonstrates actually it's quite
powerful to use this
technology it's also as a way to link
gene expression profiles
right to actually to cellular and tissue
architectures and morphologies which
could lead to sort of new and
interesting biologies
so the the final i think the ultimate
application of this technology that
we're very excited about
right is to really think of this as like
an enabling
platform enabling technology right so
sort of like instagrams
whereas in stuff you know putting in
sort of filters for
cats and for dogs right now if we
actually look at
uh you know a lot of the original
histology images from a tumor
we can actually in real time have the
algorithm generate the spatial
transcriptome profiles for many of the
key
genes and we can overlay those spatial
profiles on top of the original image
like these filters this i think can
greatly
enable prognosis and treatment design
especially where
the tumor spatial heterogeneity is quite
important
and as we've seen it also opens up new
hypothesis of how
specific genes their expressions are
linked to
changes in cellular morphologies
great and in the second part of this
presentation the second story
i also want to tell you about how
similar kinds of computer vision
algorithms
can in addition to capturing spatial
variations can also capture temporal
variations right i can capture
morphodynamics this is a collaboration
with with my fantastic colleagues
shaolin who said the biohub and tom
was at ucsf and it's worklets led by
michael
who's a great phd student in my group
so here's the setup is that you know tom
and charlene's group are interested in
studying
is microglias which are kind of the
immune cells in the brain
so here's the image that galena one of
our key collaborators took
right off this microglia over 24 hours
using label free microscopy
and what michael did is that he actually
developed a system right to
basically to automate automatically
track each and
study the morphodynamics of each of
these individual microglia cells
all right so it first tracks the
individual cells it classifies the
different cell types that are involved
and then after that you can think of the
algorithm the computational algorithm is
sort of being like a private eye
that's overlooking each of these
microglial cells
except that's doing this for thousands
of cells in parallel
right so for example if i'm interested
in this particular cell here at the
bottom
right so it's in this red square that
can the algorithm
would allow us to zoom into that cell
here on the
right here is the zoomed in version and
you can see that cells actually having
quite interesting interactions perhaps
even interacting with some neurons and
the bottom here i can zoom into a second
cell right if i want to interest in
its neighbor i can see that this
neighbor here is actually
when i zoomed in it's actually having
quite different behaviors right it seems
to be very active maybe it's even
spinning around
you know uh and even make up some of the
subcellular organelles
within this within this microglia so
it's very interesting and they have very
different behaviors
and this is these examples also
highlights one of the challenges right
because these cells
are behaving in quite complex and quite
rich dynamics
and as we mentioned before we don't
really have a very precise vocabulary to
even describe these dynamics
to to make it quantitative and this is
where a lot of the machine learning and
computer vision algorithms also becomes
very useful right as a way to learn
these representations and to learn these
dynamics and learn the vocabulary
so michael had developed quite a special
kinds of deep learning algorithms called
a particular variant
of an auto encoder so think of this as a
way to take this input these videos that
we saw before of individual
cells right and learn a way to represent
these videos in a way that's
easy to visualize to understand and
by the process of doing that it actually
learns what we're calling like a
morphology space right so this is like a
new representation of new vocabulary
that the algorithm has inferred
from these videos so
the power of this morphology space is
that if i look at any of the particular
cells right including this as an example
this cell here that we uh
zoomed in here right so the cell has
undergoes quite different
changes and interesting behaviors that
cell now actually corresponds to a
particular trajectory in its morphology
space
right so as it evolves over time it
actually traces out a trajectory
in our representation and if i look at a
different cell
right that actually traces out a
different representation a different
trajectory
and i can look at this for thousands of
cells in parallel
right and these four cells here as
examples actually trace out four
quite different trajectories you know
some of them undergo quite large
changes otherwise sort of stays
relatively consistent over time
and this is really powerful because now
we can actually look at
any cell of interest right under our
microscope and we can
we can really have a quantitative way to
look at and to analyze what is the
trajectory of these individual cells
for this particular microglia data set
it actually turned out to be quite
interesting
and that's there are two very clear
seems like
different clusters of states in this
morphology space
right so i'm just calling this blue or
red clusters corresponds to state one or
first state two
right and you can actually quite clearly
visualize these two states
by looking at you know this morphology
space right so each dot here corresponds
to
one cell and i'm showing you a couple of
examples of what's the representative
cells right in these two states
right so in the blue states so you have
these cells that look a little bit like
couch potatoes right they're
lazy they're sort of large and they
don't move around too much
right and the bottom here you have these
red cells the example of a red cell in
state two
it's much more energetic right just
moving it's spinning around
off sometimes it's interacting with
neighbors so it's much more active
and we can also show some of the example
trajectories
right of these two celsius two states
that's the
at this panel here on the top right
right so in the blue states right the
cells even when they do move
they tend to be much slower right the
speed is much
lower um and if they do move this tends
to move mostly along this long cell axis
right so it's very different types of
motion whereas it's clear from our
analysis
right that's these red cells in state
two
they're much faster when they move and
when they move they're also moving
in much more sort of a random walk in
all the different directions
right so these are the kinds of things
that's now very easy for us to quantify
and to describe because we have this
very precise
data-driven morphology space of these
traditions
of the cells and what's really
interesting here in in this example is
that
when we actually did single cell rna
sequencing of these microglias
in the sequencing expression space they
also turn out to be at least two
broad very distinct clusters right so i
also colored them blue and red
so as to be you know to be quite
suggestive about how they map onto the
morphology space
right and indeed we can actually
experimentally demonstrate and validate
that there is a connection right between
these two clusters in the expression
space was these two
morphodynamic clusters in the morphology
space
right so we did several experiments for
the patients to validate this you know
one example is
if we actually stimulate these microglia
with interferon beta
right so then the morphology space they
mostly move into this
blue state right and similarly in the
transcriptome space under the same
stimulation they also mostly
end up clustering around the particular
part of this blue state
right so by doing a set of these
different perturbations we're able to
establish a linkage between the
morphology clusters
morphodynamic states with the
transcriptome states
and i think that's really one of the
really exciting directions going forward
is that with these computer vision
technologies as we've seen in both
examples right we can learn powerful
features to represent
the spatial and temporal dynamics of the
cells
and then we can actually connect that to
rich
information from the expressions uh
either from spatial physical mix or from
singles rna sequencing
so hopefully this talk keeps giving you
some examples right a couple of examples
of how we can
really take the recent advances of
computer vision to learn about spatial
hydrogenative cells
to also learn about temporal
morphological dynamics of cells right
and really to integrate these ideas
with powerful data and readouts from
high dimensional high throughput
genomics
and i think this is especially relevant
especially promising and exciting as a
way to really study
human diseases right with these
multiple modalities of data going
forward
we in my group we've developed a variety
of ways to actually make it easy
for for people from you know for
biologists and for people who are not
computer scientists ready to interact
with these computer vision algorithms
so um for example if you go to
radiohub.com right so
this is actually a a place where we have
developed them we put diff different
interactive
visualizations and interactive versions
of many of these algorithms where
people can just interact with the models
on their browser without having to
download anything
and finally i just want to thank the
students and collaborators again
and a lot of the paid person codes for
these different approaches are available
on my website
and i also listed the references
for each of the works that i described
thanks for your attention
and please feel free to send me your
questions